So how did this happen?
Why am I sitting in front of a computer in a white mass
trying to be detected by a cheap webcam?
Well, when I'm not fighting the coded gaze as a poet of code,
I'm a graduate student at the MIT Media Lab.
And there I have the opportunity to work
on all sorts of whimsical projects,
including the Aspire Mirror, a project I did
so I could project digital masks onto my reflection
so in the morning, if I wanted to feel powerful,
I could put on a lion.
If I wanted to be uplifted, I might have a quote.
So I used generic facial recognition software
to build the system, but found that it was really hard
to test it unless if I wore a white mask.
Unfortunately, I've run into this issue before.
When I was an undergraduate at Georgia Tech studying
computer science, I used to work on social robots.
And one of my tasks was to get a robot to play peek-a-boo,
a simple turn-taking game where partners covered their face
and then uncover it saying peek-a-boo.
The problem is peek-a-boo doesn't really work
if I can't see you, and my robot couldn't see me.
But I barred my roommate's face to get the project done,
submitted the assignment, and figured, you know what?
Somebody else will solve this problem.
Not too long after, I was in Hong Kong
for an entrepreneurship competition.
The organizers decided to take participants
on a tour of local startups.
One of the startups had a social robot,
and they decided to do a demo.
The demo worked on everybody until it got to me,
and you can probably guess it.
It couldn't detect my face.
I asked the developers what was going on,
and it turned out we had used the same generic facial
recognition software.
Halfway around the world, I learned
that algorithmic bias can travel as quickly
as it takes to download some files off of the internet.